there are hundreds of villages like
these along the front line on the
ukrainian controlled side
and what's increasingly worrying the
amount of civilians that are still here
as we understand
this evacuation continues in the
separatist controlled areas
what is increasingly worrying also is
that in villages like these
there are also a lot of ukrainian
military and we've been speaking to some
of the civilians here
about their fears the military's been
here for eight years but we all feel
like targets of course the military in
the village makes the risk greater i'm
afraid to even think about an evacuation
if i would have to leave my home
suddenly with a bag of documents putin
not attending the security conference in
munich suggests he doesn't want a
peaceful solution it's very frightening
i felt the fear rising up through me
when the shelling started we've been
here since the beginning of the war but
where can we go and who can help us we
heard about the evacuation on the other
side and it's not a good sign people in
villages like this one close to the
front line are afraid they are aware of
what the russian-backed separatists on
their side of the front line are now
calling a mass evacuation of civilians
and they are asking what about our
safety too